what's the status that you know of the
Disney Fox merger and how does that
affect what's going on in the
development process here at Fox I the
status I won't speak to because that's
above my pay grade sure but we're just
continuing to make movies that make and
develop movies that we've been
developing for years now like Annabeth
or finishing movies like New Mutants and
and Dark Phoenix and Deadpool that comes
out this Christmas and exports and and
others multiple men other movies that
we've been working on we continue to
work on yeah I was gonna say I think a
lot of people don't realize that the
studio has to has a fiduciary duty to
their stockholders that if this deal
falls apart or doesn't happen you still
have time movies to come out in the
coming years yeah so yeah so that until
the deal is completely finished which is
the principle terms been agreed to turn
by the two boards but it hasn't yet
going through the sort of final
approvals that involve the government
that until that's done Fox has to remain
Fox and perform as it would as if it
wasn't for sale so yeah so for all
intents and purposes you can see is
business as usual